oui bah surpris un peu quand même parce
que ce matin j'étais bas avec bernard et
cristiano au petit déjeuner avec
emmanuel macron avec jérémy de serre le
président d'etg ac plutôt eu un propos
très consensuelle par rapport au chef de
l'état et puis après on sort dans les
allées on ce massif et donc au bout d'un
moment faut avoir le courage de ses
idées
je suis pas sur le fond 1 peut-être que
c'est tout à fait légitime leur action
mais sur la forme c'est quand même
surprenant cette histoire de toujours
s'enfermer dans un double discours
on vient cogéré avec les uns ce que vous
faites c'est bien on va vous accompagner
et puis derrière on donne la troupe et
ont fait siffler donc là c'est quand
même un peu surprenant c'est pas de
stratégie à nous apprécier la leur sur
le fond effectivement christine lambert
l'a rappelé emmanuel macron a dit il
faut changer bah oui il faut changer
enfin on est dans un système qui ne
marche pas on parle de jussiê on parle
de revenus on parle de gens qui n'ont pu
l'être au métier voilà on a un président
qui arrive en disant il faut changer un
système qui marche pas nous on a du mal
à comprendre que des gens manifestent
pour dire ne changeons rien pas les
forces de l'immobilisme essaye de se
mettre en route avec beaucoup de
difficultés depuis ce matin sur le salon
non moi je pense qu'il faut changer et
il faut qu emmanuel macron passe du
discours aux actes
et là c'est ce qui est important dans le
salon qui va arriver c'est que le voilà
au bout d'un moment et je me tourne vers
les parlementaires il va falloir qu à
travers les actes législatifs posées par
ce gouvernement qui seront débattus puis
validé dans les deux assemblées
il va vraiment falloir avoir des actes
on veut changer de cap de l'agriculture
ok pas de problème mais quels objectifs
on fixe l'objectif c'est d'avoir du
revenu comme l'a dit christiane lambert
tout à fait mais c'est surtout d'avoir
des paysans nombreux qui s'est
simplement avoir un gros gâteau contre
palaja moins nombreux c'est pas
forcément le but